[Musik]
doublemint TDI Upgrade Regierungen
müssen sich heute mit dem Wandel
auseinandersetzen in denen die
Technologie mit sich bringt die
veränderten Erwartungen und
Anforderungen der Bürger an
Servicestandards haben dazu geführt dass
Regierungen weltweit nach 9 Definitionen
für Design und Bereitstellung suchen
müssen die Exner verfolgt wichtige
Regierungen auf der ganzen Welt in der
Hoffnung Antworten darauf zu finden wie
die Regierungen von morgen aussehen
werden wie sie Spitzenleistungen
erbringen und warum Erlebnisse
vielleicht der Schlüssel sind um den
Wert hinter dem Engagement der Bürger in
der Regierung zu erschließen
dies ist deine Idee die in den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
so schaffen
Sie eine Sammlung von globalen
Perspektiven
öffentlichen als auch aus dem privaten
[Musik]
if you look in the current state of the
government Experimente sich den
aktuellen Stand des Erfahrungsbereich
der Regierung ansehen gibt es nicht
wirklich einen Standard jeder auf der
Welt macht die Dinge anders und es gibt
einen Einfluss der verschiedenen Branche
auf die Erfahrung der Regierung und in
einigen Teilen der Welt wird die
Regierung durch den Einzelhandel
diktiert und wir stellen einen Vergleich
zwischen einzelhandelsdienstleistungen
und Regierungs Dienstleistungen an was
innerhalb der Regierung geschieht ist
auch eine Nachwirkung dessen wie andere
Burschen ihre Kunden und ihren
Kundenstamm bedienen die Regierungen auf
der ganzen Welt versuchen sich an
verschiedene Dinge anzupassen und in
Zeiten politischer Instabilität Wechsel
der Regierungen ändern sich die
Prioritäten der Regierungen
[Musik]
let's talk to Jailbreak interp1 lassen
Sie uns mit Jonas nur einen Teil
sprechen ich sprach mit Jonathon über
seine Erfahrungen und die dir bei
Regierungen auf der ganzen Welt
gesammelt hat jetzt arbeitet Jonathon
mit Regierungen von Asien über den
Mittleren Osten bis nach Amerika und in
Europa und erkennt den Puls der
Regierungen und die Herausforderungen
vor denen Regierungen stehen schon essen
ist dein großer Verfechter des Wandels
als Professor als Pädagoge und als
Geschäftsinhaber seine Gedanken sind
entscheidend um zu verstehen wohin wir
gehen sollten und was Regierungen tun
sollten um Fortschritte zu erzielen
[Musik]
Withings IMAP serving sei eines der
Dinge die ich beobachte während ich das
Privileg habe viele verschiedene
Regierungen und Städte auf der ganzen
Welt zu besuchen ist die Erkenntnis dass
die Gemeinden heute viel höhere
Erwartungen an die Erbringung von
Dienstleistungen haben wenn Sie also ein
Mitglied der Community sind sind Sie es
gewohnt Verbraucher Apps auf Ihrem
Smartphone zu nutzen oder auf eine
Website zu gehen und dann nutzen Sie
einen Regierungs Dienst und der ist
nicht annähernd so gut oder vielleicht
ist er nicht einmal digital wir spüren
dass dies nicht mehr länger akzeptabel
ist und müssen das Spiel beschleunigen
wie kann man in an orange red chapter
with the Gamer ab 1 Teilnehmer sind STX
Programm systane Wiseman ich habe mit
Jane darüber gesprochen was die
Herausforderungen der Regierung sind und
womit Regierungen und die Veteranen
Gemeinde konfrontiert sind besonders in
den Vereinigten Staaten und was ihre
Erfahrungen mit dem Regierungs Dienst
und dessen Qualität sind
man kann den Unterschied zwischen einem
Google Suchergebnis und einer Google
Anzeige nicht erkennen wir brauchen eine
bessere Daten Kompetenz damit wir wissen
was zuverlässige Quellen für Fakten sind
[Musik]
auf diese Dienstleistungen einzulassen
es sei denn natürlich die Regierung
macht die ISS über ihre digitalen
Systeme zwingend erforderlich ich
erinnere mich dass vorhin paar Jahren
viele Länder sagten wir werden
standardmäßig digital aber das schließt
automatisch diejenigen aus die nicht
digital sind Menschen mit Behinderungen
ältere Menschen sie werden durch jene
Umstellung staatlicher Dienstleistungen
an den Rand gedrängt es sei denn es
werden alternative Mechanismen
eingeführt sie müssen also tatsächlich
Servicezentren bereitstellen zu denen
die Leute kommen können also wird
digital standardmäßig an den Rand
gedrängt
marloes pompa als Leiterin der
blockchain und Leiterin der KI
Partnerschaften für die Regierung der
Niederlande eine erstaunliche Ressource
sie hat so viel Wissen und Informationen
weil sie mit anderen Regierungen aus der
ganzen Welt zusammen arbeitet als
Leiterin von blockchain und einigen sehr
kritischen Programme der Regierung der
Niederlande marloes weiß vor welchen
Herausforderungen Regierungen stehen
wenn es um die Implementierung von
Technologien geht
[Musik]
cerium eine Richtlinie für alle
staatlichen Dienste eingeführt die neue
Technologien wie künstliche Intelligenz
nutzen
[Musik]
eine identitäts Programm einführen aber
1,3 Milliarden im Vergleich zu 1,3
Millionen in Estland ist schon eine
etwas andere Herausforderung Airlines
Estonia Estland ist eines der größten
Beispiele das genutzt wird wenn es darum
geht dass sie Regierung Technologie
einsetzt und effizient sind dehnschaft
was die Regierung tut ich habe mit dem
CEO der Regierung von Estland sind sie
gut gesprochen wir sprechen darüber
welche Herausforderungen er zu meistern
hatte und wir die Regierungsarbeit aus
estnischer Sicht sieht
[Musik]
der ist aus dieser Perspektive
betrachten oft sehen dass wir diese
einzelnen Interaktionen nicht als Dienst
der entwerfen müssen wir können viele
Online-Dienste buchstäblich loswerden
indem wir Dinge weg automatisieren
[Musik]
du davon die Ausleihe sind es gibt
definitiv Ausreißer und es gibt
definitiv Länder die eine solide
Anstrengungen die Rechnung machen um das
Engagement der Regierung der VAE für die
Initiative government experience
vollständig zu verstehen die einen
Präzedenzfall in der Erbringung von
Regierungs Dienstleistungen schafft habe
ich mit jemandem gesprochen der diese
Bemühungen im Büro des Premierministers
in den VAE leitet Mohammed bin Thalia
[Musik]
erzähl mir darui or even better
Johnny ist der CEO der Majid al futtaim
group in den Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten timati Tull full time Group ist
einer der größten Gruppen die den
Einzelhandel in ein Osten leitet alle
enthalte eine Menge kritisch Einsichten
wie der Einzelhandel die Regierung
beeinflusst wie Regierungen vom
Einzelhandel lernen können alle hin
arbeitet auch für das
Weltwirtschaftsforum und verschiedene
Regierungen und Gremien um Ideen und
Initiativen zu entwickeln die
Regierungen weltweit betreffen
die bessere Integration unserer
Gesellschaften in der Welt vorantreiben
können
[Musik]
Vati ist
die Möglichkeit geben sich auf das zu
konzentrieren worauf sie sich
konzentrieren möchten nämlich einen
Service der erstens um sie herum
kuratiert ist und zweitens dass er da
ist wenn Sie ihn brauchen und denken sie
tatsächlich darüber nach was der Kunde
bzw Burger braucht uns nicht was die
Regierung braucht sehr lange Zeit haben
sich die Regierungen darauf konzentriert
Dienste zu entwerfen oder diese Entwürfe
so zu implementieren dass sie den
Regierungen aus verschiedenen
Perspektiven passen und ich denke was
Sie hier sehen ist eigentlich ein
totaler Unterschied
[Musik]
geeignete um unsere Dienstleistungen zu
erbringen und zu einem gewissen
Zufriedenheitsgrad zu erreichen aber wir
wissen auch dass es nicht nur um
Technologien geht es geht auch um
Organisationsstrukturen es geht um
menschliche Ressourcen und wir versuchen
ein geeignetes Umfeld zu schaffen um
unsere Dienstleistungen effektiv und
effizient für unsere Bürger zu erbringen
den Dienstleistungen die wir von der
Regierung erhalten machen sie sich
Sorgen darüber etwas zu verpassen oder
zu vergessen ihre Rechnungen zu bezahlen
ihre Nebenkostenabrechnungen oder fühlen
Sie sich wohl weil sie wissen dass es
automatisch über Ihren digitalen
Assistenten abgewickelt wird diese Art
von Niveau und diese Art von Erfahrung
ist das was wir anstreben wo ein Kunde
sich keine Sorgen machen muss weil alles
im Hintergrund in seinem Namen läuft
Schöne ist dass es eine einzige App gibt
auf die sie dann zugreifen können egal
ob Krankenhäuser Bestattungsunternehmen
oder Behörden alle Informationen sind an
einem Auto untergebracht
international heißen
[Musik]
einer Umfrage zufolge sind dreiviertel
der Meinung dass das Kundenerlebnis sehr
wichtig für ihr Unternehmen ist aber in
der Regierung gibt es keine solche
Umfrage ich weiß nicht wie viele
Führungskräfte in der Regierung denken
dass das Kundenerlebnis oberste
Priorität hat aber ich sage ihnen dass
es 10000000 Regierungsmitarbeiter gibt
und das ist nicht für alle oberste
Priorität hat
[Musik]
sie möchten die gerade so eine gängige
Stadt oder Regierungs aufgabe ist sollte
es nicht so schwer sein wie es heute ist
die Leute freuen sich nicht darauf von
Dir erfahren sollte besser sein sie
sollten in der Lage sein eine
Genehmigung online zu beantragen ohne
dass sie irgendwo hingehen und eine
Nummer ziehen müssen und den halben Tag
in der Behörde sitzen in der Gabe Bedarf
ist in den haltetherapie focused on
customer experience from der Leiste in
den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
konzentrieren wir uns auf das
Kundenerlebnis auf Basis ihrer
Lebensumstände wenn der Kunde z.b. ein
neugeborenes Baby hat betrachten wir das
als einen Punkt im Leben an dem er
staatliche Dienstleistungen rund ums
neue Baby benötigt deshalb haben wir
begonnen die Sache aus der Perspektive
der Bündelung zu betrachten anstatt dass
ein Kunde also nachschaut welche
Behörden oder Behörden Servicecenter er
aufsuchen sollte weiße einfach welches
Paket der haben möchte ich gebe Ihnen
ein Beispiel für einen der Dienste die
wir haben er heißt Mabrouk mayak was
Glückwunsch zu ihrem neugeborenen
bedeutet und es hat mehr als 7 Dienste
in einem Schritt und mehr als 5
Zahlungen in einer Zahlung gebündelt und
alles was mit diesem Neugeborenen zu tun
hat bekommen Sie jetzt mit diesem Bundle
innerhalb von drei Stunden
[Musik]
also mir so Dorf Willi rapidly changing
world what is changing das Ergebnis
einer sich wirklich schnell verändernden
Welt ändern sich auch die Erwartungen
der Bürger die Bürger erwarten heute ein
anderes Niveau an Service auf
Regierungsebene die Erwartungen sind
eine Kombination aus dem was sie im
privaten Sektor im Einzelhandel und im
Gesundheitswesen sehen und das führt zu
einem allgemeinen Bedürfnis der Bürger
wenn Sie so wollen nach Service
Exzellenz die Bürger von heute sie und
ich wir alle nutzen Smartphones und
Technologie um Entscheidungen zu treffen
um auf Dienste zu zugreifen und es ist
sehr verbreitet einfach zu erwarten dass
jeder Service auf einem Mobiltelefon
verfügbar sein sollte er sollte auf
einem mobilen Gerät verfügbar sein aber
nicht alle Regierungen waren in der Lage
Services von einem Service Center ins
Internet zu übertragen
[Musik]
ändere die meisten sogenannten
Governance Agenden geht es den
Wirklichkeit darum dass Regierungen den
Menschen Dienste durch Technologie zur
Verfügung stellen so sehen wir Webseiten
der Regierung auf die Sie zugreifen
können Formulare zum Ausfüllen von
Pässen oder Lizenzen oder zum Bezahlen
von Steuern das ist eine wirklich
interessante Veränderung der
Managementstruktur früher hatten die
Regierungen viele Beamte viele Leute die
für sie arbeiteten um den Papierkram zu
erledigen jetzt wurde der Aufwand und
die Last wieder auf die Bürger
übertragen es ist wie in den alten Tagen
wenn Sie in einem Meeting teilnehmen
sollten schickt Ihnen jemand den ganzen
Papierkram im voraus die mussten nichts
tun sie haben nur den Papierkram gelesen
und zum Treffen mitgenommen jetzt werden
Ihnen die Datei in digital per E-Mail
oder über ein anderes Online-System
zugeschickt oder es wird sogar von ihnen
erwartet dass sie online gehen um diese
Formulare selbst der runterzuladen sie
dann zu lesen und sie dann vielleicht
auszudrucken weil sie sie vielleicht zur
Besprechung mitnehmen müssen das ist
also eine Verlagerung der Arbeit von
Regierungen zu Bürgern oder von
lohnen zu Mitarbeitern ich hasse es mich
jeden Tag auf der Reihe oder vier
verschiedenen Websites anmelden zu
müssen um Informationen zu erhalten
während sie mir einfach in einer anderen
Form geschickt werden könnten die ich
donnert Rhetorik ist natürlich dass es
für Regierungen und Bürger viel
einfacher ist bei wichtigen Dingen die
Sie tun müssen zu interagieren und das
hat zweifellos seine Vorteile es ist
jetzt sehr einfach einen Passantrag
online zu stellen oder ihre
Steuerformulare online einzureichen der
zweite Punkt ist jedoch und ich werde
das Beispiel unseres eigenen digitalen
Regierungs Dienstes verwenden es gibt
viele großartige Dinge auf Gavdos UK
wenn Sie auf der Website der Regierung
etwas über ein Ministerium oder dessen
Aufgaben herausfinden möchten ist dies
fast unmöglich und ich denke das ist ein
Hinweis darauf dass es einen Unterschied
zwischen der Erbringung von Regierungs
Dienstleistungen und der Beziehung
zwischen Regierungen und Bürgern und der
Offenheit und Transparenz in diesem
Bereich gibt
[Musik]
heute denke ich dass die Bürger
Mitgestalter eine Regierungs Erfahrung
sind es gibt eine Möglichkeit für jeden
von uns Partner zu sein und dabei zu
helfen Dinge zu erledigen eine größere
Offenheit zu erreichen Städte
progressiver zu machen und mehr
Werkzeuge für die Zusammenarbeit zu
erlangen dies insbesondere den
Mitgliedern der Gemeinschaft erlauben an
allen teilzunehmen von der
Entscheidungsfindung bis hin zu Design
Sitzungen und sogar der Entwicklung von
Lösungen es gibt einige sehr
interessante Experimente mit der
Gemeinschaft Kofinanzierung
Identifizierung von Geldern aus dem
öffentlichen und privaten Sektor um
Projekte zu realisieren die aufgrund der
Abhängigkeit von rein öffentlichen
Gelder nur schweren Gang zu bringen
waren wenn eine Regierung Daten zur
Verfügung stellt und das
Community-Mitglied sagt hey ich könnte
eine Lösung mit diesen Daten bauen wo
auch das ist eine tolle Beziehung das
ist eine tolle Partnerschaft wir haben
jetzt Software-Ingenieur die antreten
können um interessante Lösungen zu
erstellen oder um daten sinnvoll zu
nutzen und die Analysen zu lief dir den
Entscheidungsträgern helfen bessere
Entscheidungen zu treffen das ist eine
Beziehung für die wir noch nie die
Werkzeuge hatten um sie zu realisieren
eine gute demokratische Regierungs
Erfahrung ist kein Zuschauer Sport
sondern etwas an dem Sie teilnehmen
der Staat Washington ist einer meiner
bevorzugten
leistungsorientierten Organisationen es
gibt etwas dass ich results Washington
nennt jeder einzelne Kennzahl über die
Landesregierung ist online verfügbar
inklusive Analysen um mehr Details zu
erhalten und wenn der Gouverneur eine
ergebnisbesprechung veranstaltet ist die
Öffentlichkeit eingeladen es wird live
online gestreamt aber sie beziehen auch
einen oder zwei oder drei Kunden in
jedes einzelne Meeting ein wenn es also
um die Entwicklung der Jugend geht gibt
es tatsächlich Jugendliche die der
Regierung ein Feedback geben wie sich
die Dienste verbessern wo sie mehr
Verbesserung brauchen das ist also ein
großartiges Beispiel auf staatlicher
Ebene und im Moment sammeln 90 % der
Websites unsere Landesbehörden
Kundenfeedback und versuchen sich
iterativ zu verbessern
das wirklich interessantes passiert
ist all diese Knoten aus der Erfahrung
heraus zu lösen
[Musik]
für alle Dienste brauchen sie eine Art
Identität aber das klingt als gäbe es
nur eine Identität und ich nehme an Sie
haben mehrere die Sie verwenden ich habe
beispielsweise eine Identität mit der
ich mich bei meinem Google Konto anmelde
eine andere als für behördendienste ich
hoffe diese digitalen Identitäten
mehrere Identitäten gehören mir und
werden von mir kontrolliert
und ich denke es lohnt sich hier
vorsichtig zu sein denn eine einzige
identitäts in der Regierung wird das
Risiko dass sie gehackt werden könnte
und wenn dies durch den privaten Sektor
geschieht hat die Regierung nicht die
Kontrolle und kann sie nicht in der
Weise überwachen wie es vielleicht
notwendig wäre so ist z.b. in den USA
zum Reisen die transportation Security
Administration für die Ausstellung von
TSA precheck verantwortlich so dass sie
mich überprüfen und dich dann in eine
Verslein wechseln kann nun es gibt auch
eine privatwirtschaftliche Einrichtung
die das tut was ist die grundlegende
Rolle der Regierung sollte es die
Regierung sein die sagt wer in ein
Flugzeug einsteigen kann und sicher
reisen darf und wer nicht
wenn es eine Regierung die Identität
eines jeden Menschen kennt und weiß wo
er wohnt und alles über ihn weiß was
kann sie dann mit diesen Informationen
anfangen bei Migranten geht es sehr auf
dem fragen wie z.b. ob Qualifikationen
die in einem Land gewonnen wurden mit
denen in einem anderen Land kompatibel
sind stellen Sie sich also vor jeder
hätte eine digitale Identität dir
mitnehmen könnte so dass sie wenn sie
von Kenia nach Südafrika oder von Haiti
nach Brasilien ziehen tatsächlich ihre
Identität mitnehmen können ich denke das
eröffnet wirklich spannende
Möglichkeiten nicht nur für Migranten
sondern auch für Regierungen wenn wir
globale Vereinbarungen darüber treffen
könnten was ihre Parameter und was die
Berechtigungsnachweise in der digitalen
Identität bedeuten könnte das wirklich
von Vorteil sein
[Musik]
es wird also nicht die eine Technologie
sein
wird
Vitali Identität mit Datenschutz
freundlichen Technologien wie
zero-knowledge proofs oder multiparty
computation kombinieren können ich denke
das ist ein wirklich interessanter
Bereich der auf internationaler Ebene
erforscht werden sollte
[Musik]
. der ist auf die nächste Stufe gebracht
hat natürlich muss die Kundenerfahrung
im Vordergrund stehen denn sonst haben
wir keine Leute die die Dienste nutzen
und so entwickelte sich natürlich weit
über Fragen des schönen sauberen Designs
einer Online Umgebung hinaus unser
Hauptaugenmerk liegt darauf wie wir den
Prozess die Arbeit der Regierung zur
besten Erfahrung machen können und in
vielen Fällen geht es für uns darum wie
wir Abläufe radikal vereinfachen können
in die beste Erfahrung zumindest was
Studien angeht ist wenn es gar keine
gibt sondern einfach passiert als erste
ist es sehr schwer Ratschläge zu
physischen Servicecenter anzugeben sind
für uns bedeutete der digitale weg sie
weitestgehend loszuwerden
es geht die Steuerbehörde die einen
physischen Standort und vielleicht die
Post aber ansonsten wenn wir über
staatliche Dienstleistungen sprechen
sind diese zu 99% online wenn sie keinen
Zugang zum digitalen haben egal auf
welche Weise weil sie kein Internet
keinen Strom haben werden sie durch die
Bereitstellung digitaler Dienste weiter
an den Rand denkt das klassische
Beispiel ist die Idee der Smart Cities
ich sage auf das allein das Wort
smartcity ist eigentlich impliziert das
Dörfer ziemlich dumm sind eine der
größten Herausforderungen besteht also
darin dass man in einem kleinen Ort
nicht dasselbe liefern kann wie in einem
dicht besiedelten Gebiet mit voller
Konnektivität deshalb ist es so wichtig
in erster Linie Zugang zu haben
und nicht alle unsere Bürger sind
technisch versiert
außerdem haben wir
selbst die Mitarbeiter die an der
Erbringung von Regierungs
Dienstleistungen arbeiten haben wir nach
ihrem zufriedenheits Niveau befragt wir
haben uns angesehen wie sie verstehen
was Kunden wollen deshalb haben wir eine
Reihe von Schulungen durchgeführt es ist
ein training zur Kundenzufriedenheit bei
dem wir uns die Mitarbeiter an der
Frontlinie ansehen die die
Dienstleistungen erbringen wir haben sie
darin geschult wie sie ihre Geschäfte so
führen können dass der Kunde zufriedener
ist und gleichzeitig haben wir uns die
Vorgesetzten dieser staatlichen
Service-Center angesehen die wir in den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten Zentrum
für Kundenzufriedenheit nennen und wir
haben sie darin geschult wie man ein
Team von Kundenzufriedenheit
beauftragten beaufsichtigt anderer ich
bin nicht dafür die physischen Standorte
vollständig abzuschaffen denn wir sehen
dass in einigen Regionen Estland diese
die einzige Form der Kommunikation
bieten die einige dieser Menschen
tatsächlich wahrnehmen können und Sie
genießen diese Form der Kommunikation
sie gehen gerne zur Post aber in Bezug
auf das Stadtleben zum Finanzamt gehen
zu müssen und dort drei stunden dann auf
dem Papierstapel warten zu müssen das
sollte abgeschafft werden
[Musik]
Regierungs Dienstleistungen ist wirklich
klar wir brauchen eine Vorlage für
Exzellenz wir brauchen etwas dass sich
leicht anpassen lässt und einfach
eingesetzt werden kann wenn ein Land
z.b. ein Excellence Modell hat ist
dieses Modell in der Lage über
verschiedene Gruppen über verschiedene
Abteilungen und Ministerien hinweg
repliziert zu werden das ist genau das
was gebraucht wird das die Ex Programm
in den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
ist ein hervorragendes Beispiel dafür
exzellente Regierungs Dienstleistungen
haben für die Regierung der VAE oberste
Priorität Dinge wie das Treten der
Rankings von staatlichen Servicecentern
ist in den VAE nicht sehr ungewöhnlich
und das ist die Art wie die Regierung
das Land führt direkt was created direkt
wurde mit der Version und dem Verstand
geschaffen die Aufmerksamkeit der
Menschen die an Dienstleistungen
Arbeiten zu lenken unabhängig von der
Art der Kunden oder der persona des
Kunden wir müssen uns auf die Erfahrung
des Kunden konzentrieren
der ist nun Teil der T-Rex jeder es
könnte also der private Sektor sein
Investoren Startups Unternehmer Wer
teilte Jacks Plattform sein könnte hat
mehrere Aspekte wir haben das government
services Forum dass Führungskräfte aus
der ganzen Welt an einen Tisch bringt um
über government Services zu diskutieren
wir haben die GX Online-Plattform die
die Wissensbasis teilt die Regierungen
auf der ganzen Welt die Kundenerfahrung
verbessern wir haben auch die Ex
Gesprächen die GX Gespräche
konzentrieren sich darauf Vordenker aus
verschiedenen Bereichen
zusammenzubringen um über
Kundenerfahrungen zu sprechen sei es die
digitale Erfahrung oder auch die
physische Erfahrungen oder sogar
Erfahrungen die keinen Touchpoint haben
wenn Sie also z.b. zu Hause sitzen wie
fühlen sie sich mit dem was ihr von der
Regierung bekommen haben sie Angst etwas
zu verpassen oder zu vergessen ihre
Rechnungen ihrer Nebenkostenabrechnungen
zu bezahlen oder sind sie entspannt weil
sie wissen dass alles automatisch
verarbeitet wird
Antolin Weight Watchers
recipes und eine beeindruckende Nation
sie haben den Vorteil dass sie schnell
wendig und agil sind in der Art und
Weise wie sie Initiativen angehen
außerdem haben sie eine Führung die
wirklich daran glaubt digital zu werden
und die vierte industrielle Revolutionen
anzuführen ich denke wenn man diese
Zutaten zusammenfügt erhält man eine
sehr einzigartige Umgebung aufgrund der
Plattform die durch die Investition in
die das futuristische denken geschaffen
wurde
z.b. ihr Konzept rund um die zukünftige
Polizeistation es ist ein schönes
Erlebnis die Menschen fühlen sich sicher
und vieles davon geschieht durch den
Einsatz digitaler Technologien
Unterstützung durch die richtigen
Ressourcen per Video Konferenz was ich
unglaublich fand sie sehen eine Menge
Experimente und Prototypen sie sehen
sehr kühne Projekte alles von Smart
Dubai bis hin zur papierlosen
Gesellschaft wodurch die Kosten der
Regierung geringer und die daten genauer
werden all die Vorteile die wir erwarten
würden andere größten Vorteile für die
Umwelt ist der Verzicht auf Papier sie
tun es sie demonstrieren ist sie
experimentieren sie helfen anderen
Gemeinden und Städten und Regierungen
auf der ganzen Welt zu sehen was möglich
ist um diese Erkenntnisse mit der Welt
zu teilen möchte ich dass sie Dinge wie
das GX Forum schaffen das zu einer
globalen Plattform wird um zu sagen hey
welche Möglichkeiten einer Regierungs
Erfahrung gibt es wir müssen in der Lage
sein Kanäle zu schaffen die dieser best
practices sind die Dinge die gut laufen
und vielleicht sogar die Lehren aus den
Dingen die nicht immer so gut laufen
aufnehmen und mit Regierungen in jeder
Ecke der Welt teilen
sie müssen also ein wenig innerhalb
ihrer eigenen Organisation testen und
erforschen sie müssen ihre Mitarbeiter
schulen es gibt kaum vergleichbare
Projekte es ist also wirklich wichtig zu
lernen feste Koalitionen zu bilden und
welche Vereinbarungen wir brauchen
rechtliche Fragen rund um diese
Kooperationen die Regierungs Modelle
aufbauen können
natürlich ist es sehr schwierig unsere
Ideen einfach so umzusetzen jedes Land
hat seine eigenen Kulturen sowohl in
Bezug auf die Tradition als auch auf die
Umwelt und sie müssen sehen wie sie in
dieser Umgebung herausgefordert werden
und wie Sie diese Probleme wären
und es geht darum wie unmittelbar diese
im Interesse der Bürger sind für mich
sind die Bürger eigentlich wichtiger als
die Regierungen Regierungen sollten
ihren Bürgern dienen
[Musik]
einem Fünf-Sterne-Hotel erwarten können
so wurde das gleiche Konzept auf
Dienstleistungszentren der Regierung
angewendet Hassan Hamed hat uns
angeleitet die Regierung der Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate so effizient wie
Banken zu machen und rund um die Uhr zu
arbeiten wie Flughäfen seitdem dieses
Programm eingeführt wurde haben wir die
Früchte dieses Programms ernten können
indem wir gesehen haben dass ich das
Kundenzufriedenheit Zentrum in den
letzten acht Jahren deutlich verbessert
hat
wir uns auch den Spiegel vorhalten und
das ist etwas das die Leute sehen und
von dem sie denken dass die Regierung
mit gutem Beispiel voran geht
[Musik]
münzentricks
amazing time du hast also eine
erstaunliche Zeit es gibt so viel
Potential und wir brauchen zwei Dinge
wir müssen erstens zuhören und zweitens
handeln und wenn man diese beiden Dinge
zusammen nimmt macht das einen großen
Unterschied zu hat in den USA die
Veteranen Verwaltung die ehemalige
Militärangehörige betreut die jetzt
wieder im Land sind eine Umfrage zur
Kundenzufriedenheit gestartet und es
stellte sich heraus dass Menschen die an
der Umfrage teilnehmen und Feedback
haben viermal zufrieden damit der
Regierung waren als andere wir wissen
jetzt noch nicht ob ein Teil davon eine
stichprobenverzerrung ist dass
diejenigen die sich dazu entschieden
haben an der Umfrage teilzunehmen
zufriedener waren aber für mich sagt es
auch dass es einen Unterschied macht
einfach nach Feedback zu fragen wenn Sie
die Öffentlichkeit einbeziehen werden
die Leute begeisterter sein die Stadt
Santa Monica in Kalifornien hat einen
wohlfühlindex wir haben dort beschlossen
dass der Zweck dieser Stadt darin
besteht das Wohlergehen der Menschen zu
unterstützen eines der Dinge die sie
getan haben ist so The Social Media
Sentiment mining so können Sie anhand
der öffentlich zugänglichen
Informationen auf Facebook und Twitter
erkennen welche Stadtteile unter Stress
stehen welche Stadtteile Geldsorgen
haben und wie die Stadt wirklich etwas
dagegen tun kann wir haben jetzt eine
drogenbehandlung in den Gefängnissen
weil die Menschen die aus dem Gefängnis
in Kamen ein 120 x höheres Risiko hatten
an einer Drogen Überdosis zu sterben als
die durchschnittliche Person so können
wir jetzt Interventionen in unseren
Gefängnissen durchführen weil der
Datensatz uns erlaubt hat gibt's viel zu
arbeiten als Bürger sich Beteiligten und
der Regierung helfen konnten zu
entscheiden wohin das Geld geht als die
Bürger die Entscheidungen treffen
konnten gab es mehr Investitionen in
Gesundheit mehr Investitionen in Bildung
und einige der ersten Städte die dieses
Instrument einsetzten zeigten in 15
Jahren eine geringere
Kindersterblichkeit ich denke wir werden
ein viel höheres Vertrauen in die
Regierung haben denn mit all diesen
neuen Möglichkeiten die Öffentlichkeit
einzubeziehen gibt es ungenutzte Ideen
und Ressourcen und das Potenzial die
Regierung wirklich viel besser zu machen
als sie es je war
learning to implement
[Musik]
zigarrensorte future an Regierung in der
Zukunft werden sich mehr auf den Zweck
und weniger auf Dienstleistungen
konzentrieren künstliche Intelligenz
maschinelles Lernen wird die meisten der
zu erbringenden Dienstleistungen
übernehmen wir werden uns mehr darauf
konzentrieren über unsere Zukunft
nachzudenken Regierungen werden viel
mehr Zeit haben und mehr Vorsicht walten
lassen wenn es um die Lebensqualität
geht viele der Probleme die wir heute
kennen viele der Themen die sie heute zu
lösen versuchen wird es in 10 Jahren
nicht mehr geben wir alle werden in
unseren menschlichen Fähigkeiten
unterstützt werden wir werden in der
Lage sein mehr für weniger zu tun aber
wir werden auch in der Lage sein uns
tatsächlich auf die Bereiche zu
konzentrieren in denen wir den größten
Unterschied machen und den größten
Einfluss ausüben können nicht in Bezug
auf die kleinen Dinge die um uns herum
passieren sondern in Bezug auf die
Bereicherung des Lebens und wie wir
kontinuierlich Fortschritt vorantreiben
können
i believe that ich glaube dass Kathi
definitiv den nächsten Zyklus der großen
Revolution in der Technologie bestimmen
wird und was wir damit machen können
sind eine Menge Produkte und
Dienstleistungen die in der
Vergangenheit nicht möglich waren aber
ich glaube nicht dass der ki Algorithmus
eines Tages empfindungsfähig wird und
aufwacht und dann herausfindet dass
Menschen ausgerottet werden müssen
lassen Sie uns pragmatische und
realistischer sein und machen Sie sich
keine Sorgen über den SciFi Teil der
Teil der KI der wirklich aufregend ist
ist am hilfreichsten für Firmen Anwender
oder Unternehmensmitarbeiter der erste
ist das Konzept des digitalen Zwillings
das Konzept des digitalen Zwillings
besteht darin dass ein Assistent Seite
an Seite mit dem Menschen arbeitet um
die Qualität der Arbeit zu verbessern
indem alle Bananen manuellen Aufgaben an
die KI und die Automatisierung
übertragen werden damit der Mensch sich
tatsächlich auf die Dinge konzentrieren
kann auf die er sich konzentrieren
sollte nicht auf das abheften von
Papieren nicht dass das Durchforsten von
Dingen und den versucht 1000 Seiten zu
indizieren was alles von Maschinen
erledigt werden sollte der digitale
Zwilling sollte diese Workflow
Automatisierung für den Menschen
bereitstellen um effektiver und
effizienter zu werden viele der Dienste
werden globale Dienste sein und darauf
oder daneben werden sie einen lokalen
Einschlag haben aber was ich sehe z.b.
sind es die blockchain Projekte die
Registrierung von Diplomen werden jetzt
von den Ländern selbstgemacht ich
erwarte dass dies eine globale
Oberfläche wird wir bringen Menschen aus
all diesen Koalitionen und all diesen
Gemeinschaften zusammen und man diesen
Herausforderungen zu arbeiten die
hauptsächlich globale Herausforderungen
sind und ich denke im Moment ist der
erste Schritt diese Experten
zusammenzubringen sie brauchen einander
z.b. die blockchain Experten sie
brauchen mehr und mehr Daten und deshalb
brauchen Sie die Experten aus der Big
Data Arbeitsgruppe aber auch die Daten
Experten aus der Arbeitsgruppe für
künstliche Intelligenz der nächste
Schritt ist also der Aufbau von Soko
Operationen weltweit und ich hoffe dass
die Niederlande für viele Dienste das
Tor zu Europa sein können the future
garminservice.de die Zukunft der
staatlichen Dienstleistungen sollte
etwas sein das geschieht ohne dass der
Kunde danach fragt wir wissen was die
Kunden wollen warum geben wir es ihnen
nicht warum gehen wir nicht zum Kunden
anstatt einem Kunden zu uns kommen zu
lassen wir wollen es mehr mit der
digitalen Erfahrung in Verbindung
bringen die Kunden heute beim
Online-Shopping haben wo sie
Empfehlungen bekommen was Sie kaufen
sollen basierend auf ihren vorherigen
suchen auf der Jahreszeit wir wollen so
ähnlich sein und vielleicht sogar noch
proaktiver wir sind uns bewusst dass ich
die Art und Weise wie Bildung vermittelt
werden soll ändern wird wir sind uns
bewusst dass ich das Gesundheitswesen
verändern wird all diese
Dienstleistungen müssen auf eine Art und
Weise integriert werden die ist für den
Kunden nahtlos macht
ihm das
tatsächlich
funktionieren
nein machen aber wir haben immer noch
viele Relikte dabei als wir in ist dann
unsere Dienste für nicht Bürger mit der
e-resident sie geöffnet haben viel auf
das Ausländern von Zeit zu Zeit von
unseren Systemen einige ist Nische
Dokumente angezeigt wurden das ist etwas
das überarbeitet werden muss der
arbeiten auf die Vorstellung hin
nahtlose Hintergrunddienste zu haben
sobald sie geboren werden kennen wir
bereits ihren Namen wir kennen Ihr
Geburtsdatum wir wissen eine ganze Reihe
von Dingen über sie dasselbe gilt z.b.
für die Medizin wir sehen uns einige
Möglichkeiten an mit denen wir vorher
sagen können welche Krankheiten sie
haben könnten oder ob sie genetisch
bedingt sind und ähnliches
about you on the
pragmatisch und haben gesagt lass uns
herausfinden wie wir dieses Problem
lösen können organisatorisch
ohne dass wir dabei
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen für die
Technologie verletzen es ist ein sehr
ingenieurmäßiger weg und zum anderen
haben wir von der Tatsache profitiert
dass wir in diesem Sinne offensichtlich
ein kleines Land sind nicht wirklich
und wie viele Menschen dort leben ich
würde sagen und dass wir als kleines
Land eine sehr schlanke Regierung haben
was die Art und Weise betrifft wie
Entscheidungen getroffen werden wenn
mich die Länder fragen okay warum ist
Estland ein bisschen flinker sage ich
weil die Entscheidungsfindung schneller
ist und nicht zu viele Regierungsebenen
konsultiert werden müssen und so weiter
und ich habe auch in größeren Ländern
gesehen dass wenn einige
Entscheidungsprozess gestraft werden
natürlich in einem demokratischen
Kontext man dann auch größere Sprünge
machen kann der sich die Technik schnell
weiterentwickelt müssen sie auch
schneller mitziehen können
[Musik]
was die Welt wirklich verändern wird ist
wenn aufgeklärte progressive Regierungen
in der Lage sind sich leicht mit
aufgeklärten aktiven Bürgern zu
verbinden denn das ist eine starke Kraft
wenn Sie diese beiden Dinge zusammen
bringen können wir einige wirklich
erstaunliche Dinge tun diese Art von
Spannung die zwischen Gemeinden und
Regierungen baldige meint und große
Erwartungen haben dass die Regierungen
sich anstrengen aber sie kämpfen damit
diese Erwartungen zu erfüllen in einer
digitalen Welt können Sie konsistenter
liefern und Zugangsinformationen und
Daten erhalten wenn sie benötigt werden
sie schaffen einen nahtlosen Kanal
zwischen den Daten die von der Regierung
erstellt oder gesammelt werden und dem
Wunsch darauf zuzugreifen einfach weil
wir wissen wollen was die Regierung über
uns sammelt aber auch um bessere
Entscheidungen treffen und Lösungen
entwickeln zu können
wir müssen uns auch bewusst sein was das
letztlich für uns als Menschen bedeutet
wir müssen entscheiden wie wir damit
umgehen wollen in den nächsten 10 bis 20
Jahren wird es mehr Veränderungen geben
als in den letzten 100 Jahren wenn es um
Regierungs Erlebnisse geht das wird eine
bemerkenswerte Zeit
[Musik]
das Meer Erwartung in den Regierungen
gestellt werden um den Bürger besser zu
dienen und bessere Erfahrungen zu
schaffen das bedeutet eine komplexere
Welt mit neuen Interessensgruppen neuen
Herausforderungen und 9
Reaktionsgeschwindigkeiten im Jahr 2020
kämpfte die Menschheit mit einer neuen
Herausforderung der Corona Pandemie
viele Regierungen hatten Probleme im
Umgang mit der Pandemie und doch gelang
es vielen über die Erwartungen hinaus
die Bedrohung durch die Pandemie zu
kontrollieren und zu beseitigen eine
Sache die alle reaktionsschnell und
erfolgreichen Regierungen auszeichnete
war ihre Fähigkeit schnell zu reagieren
mit den Bürgern in Kontakt zu treten und
sich auf den Erfolg zu konzentrieren und
gleichzeitig in die Zukunft zu blicken
es sind diese Regierungen Denker Führer
und Wegbereiter die dabei sind eine
bessere Welt zu schaffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das überlebt MRSA so kann sie glauben
das ist einem Gesellschaftsvertrag
zwischen den Regierten und der Regierung
gibt dann müssen die Regierungen bei der
Bereitstellung von Dienstleistungen
berücksichtigen was die Menschen
wirklich von dieser Beziehung haben
wollen
[Applaus]
Sontheim fürs manchmal funktioniert die
Lösung die an einem Ort funktioniert an
einem anderen Ort nicht ich denke es ist
eine echte führungsqualifikation wenn
man sehr neugierig auf die Geschichte
und die Kulturen ist in denen man
arbeitet um die Dienstleistungen auf die
jeweiligen Bewohner oder Bürger
abzustimmen denen man dient
der Ansatz Dienstleistungen von außen
nach innen und nicht von innen nach
außen zu erbringen bedeutet einen
Paradigmenwechsel in der Art und Weise
wie die Regierung traditionell Politik
entwickelt und dann über die Erbringung
von Dienstleistungen nachdenkt
die Herausforderungen mit denen
Regierungen konfrontiert sind sind nicht
mehr technischer Natur die sind gelöst
die Probleme mit denen Regierungen heute
konfrontiert sind drehen sich eh um
raffinierte Probleme wie z.b. die Fragen
wie lösen wir Obdachlosigkeit wie können
wir die Lebensmittelversorgung
verbessern wie können wir die
Lebensqualität der Menschen verbessern
wir begannen mit der öffentlichen
Politik und konzentrierten uns sehr auf
Märkte und Marktversagen und wie die
Regierung Probleme durch Marktversagen
lösen musste ich denke das ist immer
noch eine wichtige Sache aber ich denke
wir müssen jetzt darüber hinaus gehen
und verstehen das Gleichheit und
Gerechtigkeit wirklich wichtige Faktoren
sind die wir berücksichtigen müssen es
gibt Orte die sich bei der Erbringung
digitaler Dienstleistungen hervortun
aber ich habe noch keine Regierung
gesehen die dann die Daten Wecker in für
Kunden Einblicke für prädiktive Analysen
raumbezogene Analysen und wirkliche
Leistungsoptimierung verwendet nur weil
sie einen großen umfangreichen Datensatz
haben heißt das nicht zwangsläufig dass
er ihnen in irgendeiner Weise helfen
kann wenn sie keinen Wert oder keine
Informationen aus diesen Rohdaten
erschließen können die Art und Weise wie
ich darüber nachdenke wie die Regierung
eine Rolle spielen kann besteht darin
sich wirklich auf Informationen zu
konzentrieren die für die Wähler die
politischen Entscheidungsträger die
Bürger die Einwohner oder die Besucher
wertvoll sind und diese Informationen zu
nutzen daraus zu lernen und zu iterieren
ich denke die Kunden haben Erwartungen
die sich drastisch von dem unterscheiden
was Regierungen heute an
Dienstleistungen anbieten und wir
sollten die Lücke schließen ich mache
mir Gedanken darüber dass wir in einem
Abschwung noch effizienter sein müssen
in der Art wie wir dienen mit der
Ausweitung der digitalen Dienste müssen
wir darüber nachdenken wie wir
altmodische Dienste auf eine neue Art
durchführen eine Sache die wir innerhalb
einer Stadt tun kann sich auf den
Verkehr auswirken was ich auf den
Wohnungsbau auswirken kann was ich auf
die Migration von Menschen auswirken
kann wir müssen alles innerhalb der
Systeme und innerhalb der größeren
Mechanismen betrachten und nicht nur
einzelne Entscheidungen
stellen Sie sicher dass Sie die richtige
Führung haben denn sie können nicht
innovativ sein wenn es ein Jahr dauert
es ein Business Case für einen neuen
Service genehmigt wird
[Musik]
eine Sache auf die sich die Regierung in
erster Linie konzentrieren muss ist der
Versuch die Gemeinschaft zu verstehen
und zwar auf der Mikroebene einer Stadt
und der Einsatz von Technologie ist eine
Möglichkeit dies zu tun aber auch die
Fähigkeit sich tief in die
Gemeinschaften einzubetten um die
größten Herausforderungen zu verstehen
mit denen die Menschen konfrontiert sind
und dann in der Lage zu sein diese Daten
auf eine Weise zu nutzen die tatsächlich
Veränderungen bewirken kann diese
nächste Generation sorgt sich Neon den
Planeten Umfragen zur Ungleichheit als
frühere Generationen ich denke wir
müssen die Regierung für sie attraktiv
machen
[Musik]